ambiente festivos ante un ambiente muy
diferente que al que ha vivido en las
últimas semanas en la ciudad de cali
miles de personas salieron a los puntos
de concentración que han estado
bloqueando la ciudad y el lugar de la
violencia ha habido un clima de respeto
y tranquilidad y también de festividad y
es que hoy también se ha conmemorado la
marcha de él la minga que ha estado
desde bien entrada la semana pasada aquí
apoyando los diferentes puntos de
concentración y se ha marchado
acompañada por la comisión de la verdad
y también por las naciones unidas- una
marcha que han dicho que es por
cuestiones de seguridad después de que
el pasado domingo tuvieran un encuentro
con manifestantes en los que había
civiles armados que les dispararon
dejando una decena de heridos la minga
se ha concentrado especialmente en
puerto resistencia que es uno de los
puntos clave de concentración aquí en la
ciudad de cali y allá han sido aclamada
por una centenar varios centenares de
personas al grito de gracias minga con
la marcha la minga a sus territorios del
cauca que da preocupación entre los
manifestantes que nos han confesado la
primera
que con la marcha de la minga quedan
desprotegidos y que no saben qué va a
pasar con la acción policial en los
próximos días
louis ya veíamos en el reportaje previo
que el presidente avanza en las
negociaciones con diferentes sectores
que están convocando a este paro o
sectores que no se sienten representados
en la jornada de hoy se reunió con un
grupo de estudiantes que dijeron a qué
conclusiones llegar
si como bien dices santi está aquí el
presidente duque por segunda jornada
realizando diferentes reuniones la choco
la alcaldía con la gobernación y como
dices con diferentes sectores que apoyan
el paro hoy lo ha hecho con un grupo de
estudiantes y lo que ha dicho en general
es que quiere hacer un pacto de juventud
con toda la sociedad sin embargo con los
manifestantes que hemos hablado hoy
también han mostrado preocupación y es
que hoy se han ido a reunir con el
ministro de defensa cuando esperaban
reunirse con el presidente iván duque
estos manifestantes nos han dicho que
los 25 puntos de bloqueo que hay en la
ciudad se han organizado en en una única
unidad y que mañana se van a juntar para
hacer un pliego de reivindicaciones y
esperan el viernes poder reunirse con el
presidente y bando que para desencallar
la situación